Thank You Andrew and I want to thank the
people at Harvard for giving me the
opportunity to speak here tonight I've
been in this room many many times on the
other side of the podium so it's quite
an honor to be here in front to tell you
well about this this book when whenever
I come here I always hear about
wonderful new discoveries that are made
by the astronomers who occupy this
building discoveries about black holes
and about the birth and the death of the
universe and gamma-ray burster x' and
all sorts of exciting things and i'm
here to tell you about a discovery also
tonight it is not a discovery about the
universe per se it is discovering more
about the people who investigate the
universe and because of that it's more a
personal discovery so part of what I'm
going to be telling you tonight is the
story that is in this book but part of
it also is the story of my discovery of
this story which came as somewhat of a
surprise to me when I've spoken to
audiences now over the past month in
planetariums the planetarium directors
always want to get people in the mood
somehow sort of like a warm-up act in a
way but for astronomers and in a
planetarium they can always dim the
lights and they bring up the stars so we
can imagine ourselves on a dark moonless
night with thousands of stars above our
heads not tonight
I'm afraid not from around here and I
don't have the planetarium equipment to
be able to do that so to get you into
the mood I thought I would try something
else to read a little bit of the book
the very beginning in fact the first
page of the introduction
meet the photon not just any photon your
photon what is a photon the fundamental
unit of light a sub microscopic jot of
pure energy and astronomical Hermes
delivering the message of the Stars
nothing appears to distinguish your
photon from the trillions of others that
breach the surface of the distant star
all are descended from photons born in
the stars fiery core all have survived
the turbulent outbound journey through
the stars gaseous envelope in fact only
one thing sets your photon apart from
the others streaking into outer space
this photon is destined to enter your
eye this photon belongs to you your
photon never slows along its journey
through interstellar space never strays
from its straight-line course after
centuries in the void it plunges into
Earth's atmosphere fortuitously avoiding
annihilation by air molecules and dusty
pollutants meanwhile darkness has fallen
on your side of the earth strolling
underneath the night sky you look up the
photon enters your eye strikes your
retina and turns over its luminous
energy to the biochemical process we
call sight your photon plus countless
others that proceed and trail it paint
in your consciousness the impression of
a luminous speck in the heavens on this
clear dark night thousands of such
specks are visible all together a
twinkling stellar tapestry arching high
above your head this is the visual siren
song that has beckoned observe
like yourself since the dawn of humanity
and it is the sight that started me now
some 40 years ago on the road to
becoming an astronomer from the
astronomers perspective there's much
more to starlight than the visual wallop
of a star-studded sky bound up in these
outerspace photons are clues to the
nature of the Stars themselves in the
pages that follow you will read of the
astronomers who struggled for centuries
to wrest from starlight one stellar
parameter the distance to a star and
that is what the book is about to find
the distance to a star any star the
first star the way that I got interested
in this was somewhat randomly I was on
sabbatical for my regular teaching
duties and decided I'll write a book
I've always liked writing and I decided
the book would be a general book about
the science of the Stars everything you
wanted to know about the Stars was going
to be in this book and my publisher said
all right send a sample chapter so
almost randomly I just decided distances
all right that's one characteristic of
the Stars that'll be one chapter of this
book I'll write the chapter on how
astronomers first figured out how far
the stars are and I found that the first
successful measurement of the distance
to a star was carried out in the year
1838 and it occurred to me why 1838 why
couldn't they do it in 1738 or 1800 or
why not in 1938 as a matter of fact and
so in looking at this particular
measurement of a star distance I asked
myself what had to take place before
that could be accomplished and I learned
that
had to be other observations by other
astronomers there had to be new sorts of
telescopes invented there had to come
something before this discovery you know
in a sense and then what came before
those advances and what came before
those and those and I kept tracing back
thing the family tree if you will of
this one successful star measurement
back in time all the way back to the
ancient Greeks and I realized here is
the book to measure the distance to one
star is an incredible story I learned
and what I wanted to do in the book was
not just to tell about the the science
of it but I really wanted to learn who
are these people that did that work
who is this Galileo fellow whose name
I've known since I was a kid what was he
really like
and fortunately living not too far from
one of the largest library collections
in the whole world I was able to dig up
a lot of correspondence Diaries
secondhand reports of what the
historical astronomers were like and to
my joy they were a wild and wacky
bunches turns out very entertaining to
read about I learned well what is the
big deal about measuring the distance to
a star why can't you just look at it and
and somehow measure that what what do
you measure now if you now imagine
yourself underneath a starry sky you
notice that some stars are brighter than
others the whole variety of brightnesses
of stars and so there's a natural
inclination to believe that the brighter
stars must be the ones that are most
nearby to us and the faintest ones are
far-flung stars maybe across the galaxy
and the ones that are of an intermediate
brightness they should sort of lie
halfway or someplace in between those
to extremes so that kind of way of
getting at star distances was tried but
it was quickly realized that there was a
very very dangerous assumption being
made here to say that the brightness of
a star in the sky correlates with how
far away it is because astronomers
realized after many centuries of
research that stars are a very diverse
species we can have stars that are
supergiant stars so named because they
are physically large in size putting
such a star where our Sun is we would
actually lie inside one of those stars
stars like that can easily give off a
thousand times the light of the Sun at
the other extreme you can have stars
that are small they're actually called
dwarf stars that are the size of the
earth give off maybe one thousandth of
the light of our Sun and so how do you
know when you're looking at a star in
the sky
let's say it is a bright looking star is
that truly a really bright or is it a
nearby star that looks bright because
it's close or it could it be one of
those super giants that's halfway across
the galaxy and just because it puts out
a lot of energy it looks bright there is
no Q to the distance of a star just by
looking at how bright it appears in the
sky
and so to figure out how far away even
one star is became a very difficult task
how can you do it then without making
dangerous assumptions like the one that
I just described that all stars
essentially are the same okay they are
not the same well we should be able to
do it maybe geometrically the title of
the book
parallax this technical sounding word is
the key to getting the distances to the
stars and to getting the distances to
lots of other things because parallax is
a very everyday kind of phenomenon and I
don't even have to define it because I
can show you what it is and if you wish
you can do this little experiment with
me you take your finger hold it maybe a
foot away in front of your face and look
at it just with let's say your right eye
to begin with close your left eye just
note where your finger lies and now
without moving your finger switch so
that you're looking with your left eye
only and not your right eye and if you
can blink back and forth like that again
keeping your finger still you notice
that your finger appears to shift
side-to-side that's parallax it's simply
what it is it is the apparent shift in
the position of an object when you look
at it from different vantage points now
continuing on with this little
experiment you can move your finger much
closer to your nose and repeat this
experiment blinking left right left
right again your finger seems to jump
side don't move your finger side-to-side
that's cheating okay you just keep your
fingers Stockstill and you just keep
your eyes blinking like that your finger
seems to shift side-to-side much more
than it did before
and if you hold your finger out as far
as your arm will let you and you repeat
the experiment once again you see the
parallax shift but it's smaller than it
was evidently this parallax shift is
linked with distance it is one of the
means by which our eyes sense the
distance of objects not the only means
but one of them when we look at an
object like this we are essentially
looking cross-eyed we are triangulating
to use a surveyors term on the finger
well if parallax is related to distance
and if we can our eyes are using that
astronomers even back in ancient times
would be aware that perhaps that might
be a way that we could measure the
distances to stars or in fact anything
out there the moon the planets and the
stars it's a nice straightforward
geometrical method doesn't involve any
sorts of assumptions you in principle
you look at the star from one vantage
point and note where it appears against
the background the starry background and
then you look at it from another vantage
point and it would appear to shift a
little bit and from that shift there's a
little equation you could use to figure
out how far away it is in principle
straight forward in practice next to
impossible and that's why it wasn't
until 1838 that the first star distance
was measured and if you read the
original papers of the struggle to do
this you're even surprised that they
could do it in 1838 it was an amazing
accomplishment
so what I want to do now is just show
some transparencies
that will lay out the essentials of the
story we have 2,000 years of history I'm
gonna chop off a thousand years right in
the very beginning and we're going to
try and focus just in the last few
hundred years preceding the first
success and do the best I can to lay it
out now there's a problem obviously with
trying to measure the distance to a
start using parallax on your eyes your
eyes are spaced around two inches apart
and remember the farther you move your
finger the smaller that little parallax
effect is so if you now imagine your
finger not at arm's length but oh I
don't know 30 trillion miles away you
can understand that measuring a parallax
shift of a star with your eyes is
totally impossible well there are ways
to get around this we can build devices
that effectively separate our eyes more
than just the two inches they separate
it by a few feet or so like this
rangefinder there's not an amazing thing
a bigger rangefinder
that was actually used to gauge the
height of anti-aircraft shells artillery
practice
well we can scale this up even more
let's just look at all right well
something like this you could put two
telescopes in different places on the
Earth's surface and try to see if
there's any parallax effect in the Stars
that way the farthest apart you can do
this on the earth is to the ends of the
earth so you could imagine in the top
diagram right here you could imagine
putting a telescope here and here and
triangulating on something that way in
this case the moon could do that you
don't even have to use two telescopes
you could observe the moon from here and
wait for the Earth's spin to carry you
around to the other side of the earth
and if the moon's not well the moon
can't move that's the assumption you
have to make or you have to know how it
moves you should be able to observe a
parallax effect over the width of the
earth
so that's 8,000 miles instead of the two
inches for your baseline and that's
pretty big but nowhere near enough
nowhere wide enough to be able to
actually triangulate in on a start
well after Copernicus proposed his
newfangled theory of the cosmos which
put the Sun in the middle of everything
and had the earth swinging around it I
was in the mid-1500s now we see that we
have an even larger baseline over which
to measure we have the whole Earth's
orbit now that's a hundred eighty-six
million miles away and so that means
that maybe maybe now we'd have a chance
to see a little parallax shift for a
star that might lie literally trillions
of miles away and I just did a little
calculation here to give you some idea
of the actual dimensions of this sort of
triangle that you see formed right there
okay this is obviously not to scale if
well let's say that we represented this
size here the Earth's orbit by about two
and a half inches okay just like your
eyes so if this 186 million miles we
scale down to two and a half inches then
this distance here to a nearby star
would be around six miles away so the
task for astronomers to accomplish was
equivalent to using your eyes to
triangulate on an object six miles away
the first astronomer to really set out
to do this in a somewhat sophisticated
way was this fella Tycho Brahe Hey
a Danish astronomer unusual fellow with
a very eventful life and I can use that
phrase to describe most of the
astronomers that were involved in this
whole parallax effort Tycho Brahe Hey
Danish by birth lived in the he lived
and worked in the late fifteen hundreds
so he was right after Copernicus he was
the greatest observer of his day he had
no telescope because the telescope had
not been invented yet so all of his
observations were made by eye but aided
with various sorts of instruments that
are sort of extensions of the modern day
protractor he could measure positions of
stars angles above the horizon and so on
and he was born through wealth happened
to be kidnapped when he was a year old
by his uncle that the uncle and Tico's
biological father had a little they were
loggerheads about this particular issue
but eventually it was settled and the
uncle raised Tico in a very privileged
lifestyle but he was a very angry man
all throughout his life and I guess the
the most famous anecdote about his life
story the one that's the most colorful
is that he got into a duel when he was
in his 20s purportedly over mathematics
but that may be totally untrue and he
was on the raw he might have been a
better
mathematician than he was a swordsman
because the result of this duel was that
he lost part of his nose however you can
see that there's definitely a nose on on
this tico portrait here but looks a
little unusual because it is a
prosthetic nose he made it himself
very handy fellow but somehow with all
of that going on in the background he
made some incredible observations and he
proved and this was very important he
proved that a comet that came around was
not in the Earth's atmosphere
he used the whole parallax idea to show
that the comet was actually somewhat far
away was out among the planets and was
not a gaseous discharge within our
atmosphere and that was quite an
incredible feat and so the King of
Denmark rewarded him with an island gave
him a whole island and gave him a nice
budget so that he can build this home on
the island now this is actually an
observatory the conical shaped areas
here underneath those are the
instruments that Tico used but he also
lived in quite elegant style here you're
on a board this is called just give you
an idea of what one of his instruments
looked like you could see their various
markings on here and there is an
observer here who is sighting a star
through this whole very tedious tedious
work but Tico carried it out for decades
and decades and decades and among the
various things he was trying to do was
to see if he could detect the parallax
of a star and hence sort of create the
third dimension pinned down what the
third dimension of outer space is but he
did not succeed
and in retrospect we know that he had no
chance of succeeding because you needed
a telescope
there's the ancestor of the telescope
pair of spectacles that date back
probably to the 1400s or so spectacles
themselves were invented in the late
well I can pin it down even more around
the 1280 s the historical records are
that good but the telescope the
outgrowth of that was not invented until
well shortly after 1600 took 300 years
for somebody to figure out if you took a
couple of lenses and put it one in front
of the other
you have a pretty useful device there
it's actually much more difficult than
I'm implying by that statement but
around 1600 the telescope was developed
a very crude spyglass we might call it
didn't magnify very much
Galileo however saw the potential in
this design brilliant man and I really
don't have to tell you much about him
because this portrait by Tintoretto says
it all that's what he was like okay he
you would rather be his friend than his
enemy he was not a good enemy to have
but he also saw opportunity when it
presented itself
he took the spyglass design and improved
it to make a real telescope an
astronomical telescope which as we all
know he pointed up to the heavens and
made wonderful discoveries now Galileo
was also aware of this parallax
potential the idea that maybe now with
the telescope he could triangulate on
the Stars he knew it was not even worth
a try he knew that his telescope as
wonderful as it may have seemed in those
days just was too
- wobbly basically and too crude to make
the kind of sophisticated measurements
of a star position that he knew would
have to be made to achieve success
nevertheless even though he never tried
to measure the the little parallax
wobble of a star he did set down in
detail how other astronomers succeeding
generations might carry it out so he was
a very forward-thinking scientist
one of Galileo's suggestions was in fact
carried out in the mid 1600s now several
decades after Galileo's first worked
with the telescope carried out by an
English scientist named Robert Hooke
hypochondriasis entire life he was and
and the effect that it had on his
stomach so if you want to know there's
an excerpt of one of those Diaries in
the book apparently he was not the only
person in those days to keep a record
like that because I guess food wasn't
quite as safe as it was or is is these
days but a very interesting interesting
man he built a telescope and here is the
telescope looks a little like a house to
me and indeed he built it right into his
house this is a rather unusual telescope
here you see something that looks like a
telescope tube and that's that's part of
the telescope
there's a lens way up here on top Hooke
had drilled a hole through his roof and
stuck this stovepipe like thing there
with a lens in it and so the light would
come in from outer space down through
this tube and you can see there was a
little hat on it so he could close it up
when he when it was raining the light
would come down through here we had to
drill a hole in his floor to I don't
know if the landlord was pleased about
this and then the light came down here
and right there's a little eyepiece and
this that's his couch okay this is a
telescope that points only straight up
and you literally lie on your back to
look through it what possible use could
such a rigid
telescope be it only points straight up
but nonsense is this but it's very
clever this thing is fixed it doesn't
wobble at all at least a principle that
was the big problem that that Galileo
envisioned any telescope he could
imagine would be literally too wobbly to
make a sophisticated measurement of this
star position if you're looking for a
little wobble of a star that means that
you're gonna have to observe that star
night after night after night for at
least some months preferably over a six
month period or so you can and so you
have to be able to determine the nightly
position of That star with just
stupefying accuracy you can't do it with
a wobbly telescope but this telescope
doesn't wobble sure it's as a limitation
it only points in one place but in
London where Hooke was doing his work it
just so happened that there is a star
there a fairly bright star that passes
right overhead anywhere on earth there
will be a star that passes right
overhead there will be many stars that
pass right overhead but this is a very
bright star fairly bright star that by
the name of Gama Draconis and so here's
the thinking how could you see if gamma
Draconis has that little telltale wobble
as the earth moved around in its orbit
well you see gamma Draconis passing
through the telescope every night and if
the earth swings around in its orbit
that means that six months later you're
way over here the earth carried that
telescope way over there to different
vantage point and so that star should
pass through the telescope again but
maybe in a little different spot that
would be your parallax
hook made a grand total of four
observations with this and complained in
the paper that he finally wrote
complained about how horrible this thing
was because when it was windy the tube
would tip when the Sun was when it was
warm on some nights the tuber tip the
other way there are all sorts of things
that made this crude telescope difficult
to use nevertheless he claimed success
said I measured the first distance to a
star then of course nobody believed him
and rightly so that was room in the
1660s or so
well here's sort of the improvement of
that idea here is also a vertical
telescope that has the ability to swing
a little bit so it doesn't point only
straight up but generally straight up
the astronomer James Bradley also in
England 1720s or so was using this
instrument to do the same thing that
Hooke tried to do but this really was a
precision instrument and the interesting
thing about this telescope once again
you have it poking through the roof this
was not Bradley's house by the way there
was his aunt's house but she kindly
consented for her nephew yes you may
drill a hole in my roof and wouldn't you
know it she she moved away after a while
and the new owner said sure come in make
your observations anytime you want there
had to be a hole drilled in the floor
this is a one-story house this is the
basement or the coal cellar probably one
of the few telescopes ever made where
you have to go down into the cellar in
order to view the sky but he did and he
did definitely detect a wobble in the
position of a star he was really excited
but well I can't go into detail let me
just say that the wobble was miss timed
a parallax you know the way the star
should wobble on a given night if you're
on this side of the Earth's orbit you
know that that star would appear off in
that direction and if you're on this
side that star should be over there and
that constellation
well this star that he was observing
wobbled but it wobbled three months out
of sync it wasn't right
so I go into detail in the book what
this is all about but what he discovered
was really the effect on starlight by
the moving earth not where the earth is
but just the fact that it has a speed to
it it's moving through space same sort
of thing if you're driving in your car
and there is let's say some snow coming
straight down if you're driving along at
a good clip the snow appears to be
coming in tilted that's pretty much what
was happening with the light going
through this telescope suffice it to say
that he did not discover parallax he
discovered something else that was very
very interesting called the the
aberration of light but it was proof
that the earth actually was moving so in
essence here we had witness James
Bradley not a star distance but actual
proof that Copernicus was right after
all
the earth is in motion you ever want to
take a view of the peak through that
telescope there it is at the Greenwich
Museum in England just seat yourself
down there and do what Bradley did but
you've got to do it every clear night
hour after hour no matter what else you
have on your schedule the dedication of
these astronomers is just phenomenal
this is not a part-time task
you'll come to see next up if this were
a baseball team of astronomers they're
striking out one after the other and now
we have the power hitter up William
Herschel fascinating story also musician
he composed things you can actually buy
a CD of William Herschel's music and
it's somewhat undistinguished I've heard
but but but not bad I mean he was a
professional musician and he just got
really really interested in astronomy
made his own telescopes and observed
like a madman he literally would run
from a music lesson over to the
telescope or if he was rehearsing his
chorus or conducting something in the in
the intermission or time between
movements he'd look outside to see what
was going on in the sky very very
dedicated amateur astronomer but his
life changed when he discovered
something in the sky that wasn't
supposed to be there he discovered a new
planet the planet Uranus made him an
instant celebrity and I say in the book
that if People magazine had existed in
the late 1700s William Herschel would
have been on its cover he was a true
celebrity in the late 1700s for having
discovered a new planet you have to
understand that since antiquity it had
been assumed that there was Mercury
Venus Earth Mars Jupiter Saturn that's
it and suddenly this musician comes
along and discovers a new planet well he
was a phenomenal astronomer and made
many many other discoveries that are
just too numerous to mention
as I said he liked to build his own
telescopes and he was convinced that the
bigger the better so here you see the
bigger this telescope is 4 feet wide as
a heavy metal mirror down at the bottom
collects light that comes in from outer
space reflects it back toward that
opening where William Herschel or his
assistants would actually look at the
light through an eyepiece a reflector
telescope this was the biggest one that
he ever made it was not a tremendous
success and in fact he liked to use
somewhat smaller telescopes for most of
his work but it just gives you some idea
of what a telescope a big telescope
looked like in those days he decided
that he was gonna solve this parallax
problem the quest for parallax Herschel
decided was going to end with him and he
followed another suggestion of Galileo's
Galileo brilliant brilliant man Galileo
said as I already mentioned wobbly
telescopes no good what we're gonna do
what we need Galileo said is a little
landmark in the sky against which to
measure the position of the star whose
distance we want to detect sure a star
might do this kind of wobbling but if
it's the only star that you can see in
your telescope it's hard to gauge that
night after night after night but if
there's another star a presumably
faraway star right near it the faraway
one will show little or no parallax
shift and the nearby one should have a
parallax shift that although small will
stand out double stars
is what Galileo suggested astronomers
might look at and so Herschel spent
decades first discovering and cataloging
these double stars and then very very
carefully looking for any of those
little wobbles in those pairs one would
stay still but the other one should show
the little parallax shift very clearly
what did he find out he saw a shift but
it wasn't this sort of thing it was this
sort of thing he showed that these
double stars at least most of them are
not just random alignments from our
point of view it's not you know a nearby
and a faraway star that from your
vantage point just look like they're
close together in the sky Herschel
actually showed from decades of careful
observations that some double stars are
really pairs of stars in orbit around
one another so he discovered what we now
call binary stars but never saw a
parallax after decades he had to admit
that he had failed the power hitter
something had to happen there had to be
something drastic that had to happen
before astronomers could measure the
distance to any star and it lay in
technology there had to be an
improvement in the telescope's this may
look kind of impressive especially since
it was pointed the other way before
it may look impressive but look at that
crude crude mounting you're not gonna
pinpoint anything and that kind of
telescope and so starting it's always
hard to say starting when but around
1800 he started to see telescopes that
were more refined more sophisticated
telescopes were turning they were
changing they were turning from just
magnifying instruments into measuring
engines you could really pinpoint the
positions of stars very very precisely
that was the key to measuring this
parallax so here's one kind of
instrument here you can pivot it around
this point up here and make readings
along this arc here that too is in the
Greenwich Museum you had some really
gorgeous looking instruments such as
this one this is the famous circle of
piazza Italian astronomer in Palermo
this instrument still exists celebrated
its 200th anniversary this year earlier
this year where you might ask is the
telescope this is the telescope okay
that tube all of these other things here
all of this it's bracing they're going
now to some tremendous lengths
steady these telescopes I look at the
telescope itself is a tiny little tube
and they surrounded with all of this
sturdy metal so that it will not wobble
in the least just another beautiful
looking instrument a friend of mine when
I sent her this picture she sent it back
and she had drawn little Ferris wheel
cars all under but again pay attention
to all the trouble that was made to
stiffen this thing so it doesn't expand
or contract when the temperature changes
doesn't wobble in the lease this is all
happening now in the early 1800s if
there is one figure who really
symbolizes the sudden leap in the
capabilities of telescopes it is Joseph
Fraunhofer now those of you who are
familiar with with science may know the
name Fraunhofer from the Fraunhofer
spectral lines in the spectrum of the
Sun Fraunhofer was a a craftsman he was
a telescope maker optical scientist you
might say of extraordinary capabilities
but his life is one of the most
remarkable lives I have ever read his
life story could have been written by
Dickens worn into poverty orphaned at
age 11 his mother and father died within
a year of one another the mother tumbled
down the basement stairs and was killed
so with no parents he was shipped away
to serve as an apprentice to a mean
glass cutter ornamental glass cutter
Munich six years of this servitude the
master would treat him as a slave his
room windowless no candles allowed no
books for sure not allowed to read
nevertheless Fraunhofer had an
insatiable curiosity he smuggled in
science books and read as much as he
possibly could when he was 14 so about
halfway through this six year
apprenticeship miserable because he was
not allowed to attend even the Sunday
apprentices school the building in which
the workshop lay collapsed burying
Fraunhofer the master and the Masters
wife the wife killed crushed master was
extricated rather quickly and Fraunhofer
was buried underneath this rubble for
some four hours or so they could hear
him calling out and they eventually dug
through the rubble and they got to him
amazingly enough when the building had
collapsed he just happened to be
standing next to a sort of an artificial
wall of piled up crates a beam had come
down and wedged itself against that wall
and instead of crushing him protected
him from everything that came down and
if that isn't enough okay again this is
Dickens writing the story but it's true
when he is extricated from the debris
the future king of bavaria is on scene
and recognizes in this scrawny
fourteen-year-old boy a symbol of hope
for his downtrodden people economic
times were terrible and more or less
decided to adopt him
and so I write I write a scene in the
book where I imagine what it must have
been like for him to go to the castle
the summer castle at nymphenburg where
this
well then prince was living I went on
the web and sure enough somebody had for
the head their vacation pictures posted
and nymphenburg is an amazing place so
you can just imagine what it was like
for this fourteen-year-old to be
strolling up there to be given some
money by this Prince to be told that he
used to consider the prince like his
father
well you can be sure that Fraunhofer was
allowed to attend sunday classes after
that and was given a candle and a nicer
place well to just cut this story short
he educated himself and became the
greatest telescope maker that had ever
lived up until that time made some
extraordinarily sophisticated
instruments many of which still exist
one of them is this one nine and a half
inches in diameter
that's rather large thing a refractor
telescope has a nice clear lens at the
top eyepieces at the bottom it looks
deceptively simple but it is really a
new high-tech kind of instrument we're
around 1820s now and nothing like this
had really been made before heavy heavy
oak steel bands reinforcements
everywhere all sorts of things done to
make sure that that telescope doesn't
wobble in the slightest that the tube
doesn't even warp under its own weight
there was an astronomer named Wilhelm
Strava and I don't have enough time to
tell you about his interesting life but
it did involve kidnapping and exciting
rescue
I don't know any of onerous today that
go through these things I don't know why
it is but when he became an astronomer
he happened to be passing through the
workshops of Joseph Fraunhofer and saw
this thing being built
nobody had claimed it yet so he said
don't sell this thing I'm gonna go back
to my home observatory
University of dorpat and what is now
Estonia I'm gonna ask the University
trustees to pay this exorbitant sum to
get this biggest telescope in the world
and they said yes times were different
back then
so Struve uh got ahold of this famous
telescope which still exists by the way
and he used it now to try to detect the
parallax of a very well-known star
called Vega and we know that from our
summer skies he made some initial
observations which showed the wobble he
was a good scientist though and he
didn't he didn't announce that he had
definitely measured that parallax shift
carefully enough he said I'm gonna go
back and do some more work but other
duties called then he had to actually
take a break for a while from his
research so he was halfway through you
might say his his task of trying to
measure this star distance mid-1830s now
Struve his friend Friedrich Bessel an
observational astronomer everybody
looked like baked over Beethoven in
those days Friedrich Bessel was
interested in the same problem an
incredible observer good mathematician
he knew the task had the difficulty of
the task of measuring the distance to a
star he had actually tried it on several
occasions during his career but when he
heard that his friends Dhruva was
actually working on the problem he
decided to redouble his efforts and see
if he could measure the distance to a
star the reason why he felt he could do
it it's because he had another
Fraunhofer instrument this one is much
smaller than the other one it but the
telescope needn't be big we're looking
at fairly bright stars but you see again
very sturdily made this is a special
kind of refractor telescope called a
Helio meter and to make a Helio meter
you cast your flawless glass lens in
this case it was around six and a half
inches in diameter
and you cut it in half the astronomer
John Herschel William Herschel son was
actually visiting the Fraunhofer
telescope workshop when they were sawing
that thing in half that lens at the
flawless lens and he essentially said
his heart stopped when he saw that but
they did cleave it cleanly and I won't
go into details as to why but suffice it
to say that doing that and providing it
with various kinds of measuring
instruments they can slide these lens
halves relative to one another and
measure star position
with great great accuracy so now we're
1838 bessel observes every clear night
now he has an observatory in Prussia or
what was then Prussia
you can imagine how cold it gets in
Prussia but every clear night when the
star that he was looking at was
available he would study it sometimes he
said 16 times a night and then by
October he had what he felt was enough
data to make an announcement now to make
this even a little more interesting okay
so we have two people who are working
more or less simultaneously there was a
third person before Strava and Bessel
had even set their telescopes on their
target Stars he had already completed
his observations this is Thomas
Henderson a Scottish astronomer posted
to South Africa I'm sure South Africa is
a lovely place now but in the 1830s it
was a wild wild area extremely remote
and Henderson the astronomer was a
proper Scottish gentleman and he hated
being there he called it the dismal
swamp and he wrote letters home
complaining complaining complaining
about the bugs and the hippopotamus in
the pond the leopard lying on the dome
yet to shoe the leopard off the dumb
wild place but in the southern
hemisphere there is a star called Alpha
Centauri which we know now is the
closest star to our solar system
therefore the easiest to get a parallax
for and while Henderson did not set out
to measure the parallax of That star he
did measure its position for a while
first
months at the same time that he was just
measuring the positions of other stars
too so
so if unwittingly he had accumulated
enough data that he could later on
detect in his data the indications that
Alpha Centauri showed this little
telltale parallax shift this was before
as I said the other two astronomers had
had even sent out to do their work but
Henderson sat on the results he did not
publish it because by this time and I've
left out a lot of the participants in
this whole quest for stellar distances
by this time astronomers were really
suspicious of anybody who claimed they
measured a parallax because there have
been there had been so many claims which
had just been disproven so Henderson
didn't want to take the chance of being
ridiculed he knew that his data was more
or less incomplete and so he waited
Bessel finished his work in November
1838 made the announcement that he had
measured the first distance to a star
and if you look at his original paper
which I have the detail is amazing the
analysis is just incredible the number
of observations that he made astounding
and you can understand that finally
astronomers would tend to believe him he
had an excellent reputation for being
careful for being a good and honest
observer and so Bessel is generally
accorded the title of being the first
astronomer since the time of the ancient
Greeks to measure the distance to a star
November 1838 a month later
Henderson emboldened by Bessel's result
publishes his preliminary result which
is later confirmed and a few months
after that
Ruvo finally got to go back to his work
and he published his result so after
some 2000 years in this marathon of
attempts to measure the distances or the
distance to any star three people
succeeded within a year's time so it's
quite amazing
hence the subtitle of the book the race
to measure the cosmos I didn't mention
which star Bessel looked at which star
he measured eventually I'll get it the
right way there is okay the
constellation of Cygnus the Swan and the
star that vessel focuses attentions on
is that one right there with the number
61 on it well you you have to wonder why
that one I mean look right over here is
the star Vega
that's bright and Deneb also very bright
even this one number 53 is brighter than
that little speck there was something
very unusual about that star 61 Cygni
that more or less convinced Bessel
that's the one I'm going to spend a
dedicate a year of my professional
career on back in the early 1800s the
astronomer Piazza whose telescope we saw
before one of those round jobs he found
that the 61 Cygni is moving pretty
quickly as stars go across the sky it
was nicknamed the flying star now that
doesn't mean it literally flies like a
meteor across the sky but as far as star
movements go its movement was pretty big
and Bessel reasoned well
if stars generally move more or less at
the same speed or some kind there's some
kind of average speed the ones that are
closer by to us will appear to be moving
faster than the ones that are way across
the galaxy and this is no common sense
kind of observation that we also can see
just in our everyday lives and so
because that star had a large proper
motion as astronomers call it Bessel
focused on that one and he was
successful from a modern standpoint he
did it okay the the distance of that
star has been measured with very modern
instruments now very carefully and
baesell was quite close to the modern
value henderson who measured the
distance of Alpha Centauri also came
pretty close
Struve a-- his results were sort of
uneven so it's it's kind of hard to tell
with his he definitely did observe a
parallax shift in Vega but the actual
number he came out with is somewhat
uncertain that is more or less the story
of how it was done but too close since I
read the first few paragraphs of the
book I'm not going to redo the last few
paragraphs and don't worry I'm not
revealing the the ending I already
already revealed the ending here well
the last chapter is more or less a a
summary of what came after this but what
did I learn from this book is what I
wanted to put here at the end you know
this is this is the first book that I've
written and I emphasize the word written
because I do have a couple of other
books that are just filled with
astronomical data that was more or less
compiled by computer so that doesn't
really count
this is the first book of of my words
you might say and so I wanted to end it
in an appropriate way and as a
first-time author and I assume this this
kind of thing happens to other authors
too you get near the end of the book and
you realize there's this black hole at
the end the last sentence the last
sentence isn't written what is it going
to be it's got to be something really
pithy it's got to somehow comment on
what the book was about or what the
author took away from the book and as I
was getting closer and closer to that
that black hole the last sentence that
didn't yet exist I was throwing all my
creative ideas at an end like the black
hole will do it just swallow them up now
just to show you how serendipity works
as it did for some of the astronomers
here where do you get your inspiration
for such a thing how do you summarize a
book you know sentence the lesson of the
book you find your inspiration sometimes
in the most unexpected places
it's not in the books of poetry that I
was looking at it was not in the books
written by Carl Sagan or Dava Sobel to
get the creative juices flowing didn't
find it there philosophers were of no
help at all I was attending the middle
school graduation of my older son and
some of you may know what that kind of
experience is like hot day and you sit
in the big gymnasium and the students
come up and give talks about this how
they save the whales or we should not
pollute this or you know they they they
reminisce about their life and I mean
they only have what is it for thirteen
or fourteen years of life and yet
they're going on and on the one
and so I'm they're not really focusing
on the fact that my son is about to
graduate he's gonna be called up to get
this little diploma from middle school
I'm thinking about my last sentence
what's it gonna be the deadlines
approaching am I gonna submit a
manuscript that just says fill in
something here and then mr. ken yee the
assistant principal stands up and he
starts to talk very mild unassuming man
and he tells the students that they
should think a little bit about all the
people who help them along the way
parents teachers friends whatever and he
said that in his family there has been a
Chinese proverb that has been passed
down through the generations and he told
the students that proverb and I will get
to that proverb because that became the
last sentence of my book because it just
summarized so well what the book was all
about Thank You mr. Yi the parallax
quest is a chronicle of human striving
toward a common goal it refutes the
misperception that science is a steady
forward march to enlightenment a
misperception by the way fostered by
many science textbooks that for the sake
of brevity highlight only scientific
advancement take that from a teacher
science as exemplified by the long hunt
for stellar parallax is rife with
failure false assumptions unfounded
optimism jealousy egotism in short
science is a truly human Enterprise look
beyond its numbers and its logic and its
supposedly objective facade and you will
discover as I have to my delight the
imperfect yet inspiring characters who
populate the unvarnished story of
scientific achievement through the
colorful lives I have lately come to
know my own view of the parallax tale
has acquired a new dimension a human
dimension as revealing in its own way as
the third dimension the parallax hunters
themselves struggled to establish in the
cosmos the portraits I've collected for
this book once almost interchangeable in
my mind now resonate with individual
accounts of frustration failed dreams
and through it all the longing for
success in the centuries long pursuit of
the first seller parallax these
astronomers are not just pioneers but
heroes if only for facing down such
daunting odds for persevering where
others might have given up it is to them
that modern astronomers owe a debt of
gratitude in this age of technological
wonders where computer screens glow and
satellites soar and the accumulated
knowledge of centuries can be accessed
at a fingers touch it is easy to forget
how we got to where we are yet as the
Chinese proverb wisely counsels Thank
You mr. Yi when you drink from the well
remember the people who dug the well
thank you
and I just remember before you asked a
question if we could get the boom mic to
you so if you wanna raise your hand
we'll send the guy over with the wife uh
Tycho Brahe he's island is the building
still standing
the building was let me back up a second
his funding was cut when the King died
okay the king's son took over and as
these things happen with a change in
administration his funding was cut and
he stormed off the people on the island
who were not too happy to have him as
their sort of a ruler which essentially
is what he was acting like took apart
the building brick by brick and used it
to build their own houses so there is a
little foundation hole and that's all
that's there we have assumed that the
background star is absolutely fixed the
star whose were measuring the parallax
is moving all right but the back out
star absolutely leaks is that so yes
your your hope is your hope is that the
background star is sufficiently far away
that it doesn't have any discernible
wobble in its position even if that's
not a hundred percent true though you
can still measure what's called a
relative parallax even if you have a
case where there are two stars in the
sky and one has a big wobble and the
other one has a little one that's still
enough that you can at least determine
that one of the stars well you can
determine the relative distance of the
two would be very inaccurate in that
case it would be yes yes but fortunately
there are many many stars out there so
you very often will have a comparison
star as they call it within the field of
vision that you can look at what's
interesting is that considering these
two astronomers Strava with his big
tellus
go and baesell with the little one
vessel ironically had a tremendous
advantage over Struga the little
telescope could see a relatively wide
swath of sky trubiz telescope was
powerful and in a very very narrow field
of view so even if Struve I had wanted
to look at this star 61 Cygni that
Bessel eventually settled on he couldn't
because his view was so narrow that
there were no other stars in the field
of view that he could use as fixed
landmarks to measure the the parallax
wobble how are the telescope's of the
different astronomers preserved well the
heart of a telescope is its glass lens
which doesn't decay at all there are a
lot of brass fittings on it which you
just polish it up and it'll be in good
condition some of the wooden tubes do
decay after a while so you would have to
certainly take care of them well these
telescopes would either be in the hands
of amateur astronomers who bought them
or they'd be in the hands of
universities or observatories so they
would always have people on staff who
would take care of these instruments
nowadays a lot of these instruments of
course are our museum pieces and
essentially there's nothing much you
have to do to them to keep them in
fairly good shape I will point out one
sort of sad note this telescope the one
that the one that Bessel had used to
measure that first star distance you
know having been in astronomy for a long
time you sort of get to hear about all
the famous telescopes and where they are
and I realize I've never heard anything
about this one where it is
so I did some investigation and finally
determined that this telescope was still
in the observatory that Bessel had
founded during World War two and was
totally destroyed in the bombing of that
city Konigsberg which I guess now is
called Kaliningrad so effectively the
new city of Kalinin grande is built on
the ruins of vessels old observatory and
the instrument unfortunately was
destroyed and is laying there underneath
yes yeah
Tycho Brahe you tolls a couple of
instruments he used but what other
instruments did he use what he was
measuring the Stars because he didn't
have beyond the telescope's like that
other ones did what other things did he
use they were all you might say
variations on a protractor some of them
had an entire circle with sites along it
and the circle was marked off in
whatever degrees and fractions of a
degree you had those those kinds of arcs
called quadrants quarter of a circle so
there were all variations of that sort
of measuring instrument some of them
made rather large because well they
didn't even have microscopes I guess in
those days and so that you they well
they had to be able to mark them with
very very fine rulings to measure the
the degrees and the fractions of the
degree so they physically had to make
these things big those days there's
nobody near caliper how their methods at
small things well they did it by eye
they had you know on that instrument
that they show they had the little
markings and degrees and in fractions of
a degree and they tried to mark them as
finely as they possibly could
and and his accuracy was remarkable
considering the fact that he worked just
with the eye yes sir he was playing just
popping up refractor telescope actually
magnifies in star works okay fairly
straightforward you have at the the
large end the top end the business end a
concave shaped lens and then at the
bottom end you have a very small
either's could be a single lens of that
shape it could be even
I said concave and I'm sorry I'm in
convex convex this is convex at the
other end you can have either convex or
concave you can have a mixture of them
it depends on the design of the
telescope but essentially you have a
main lens and a magnifying lens so in
essence the main lens makes an image in
the telescope tube and the eyepiece is
like a magnifier to magnify that image
what is the degree of accuracy which can
be achieved using current technology for
parallax measurements well I guess that
they do it by us these samurai
satellites
yes yes Hipparchus or so yeah yeah well
okay there's a table in the back of the
book where I'm glad I put this thing in
here because I wouldn't have remembered
it otherwise here it is okay relative
measurement precision smaller number is
better so I'm just going to do it
relatively I'm not going to say it's a
whatever fraction of a degree okay so if
say Tico right
his relative measurement precision how
accurate he could be if we represent
that by the number 60 million
okay the instruments now could measure
relative to that number 60 million about
a thousand so what does that that's
sixty thousand times better than what
Tyco could do and in the future we're
gonna go from that one thousand down to
about three yeah okay
one more question
yes what was the name of the first star
to have its distance measured that star
is 61 Cygni
doesn't even have a special name that's
all that it's known as let me just say
that I guess there are no books
available but I do I do have some
postcards that give information about
the book which I guess I can okay before
you leave we have some volunteers event
pass no tickets it's a free raffle so
long we will have some folks coats for
the crowd right now very quickly we'll
do a draw for the three books including
professor Hirschfeld so as soon as you
get a ticket everybody gets a ticket
we'll bring them up front
professor barring and then from there
those that are interested can go to the
great refractor for a short tour it's
well worth it
you'll see some instruments that look
quite like those that were shown in the
diagrams so bear with us a moment while
we pass these out and we'll do a quick
raffle
okay and get those out - yeah okay cool
it okay